INSURANCE PAY OUT.
DID NOT PLAY OUT THAT WAY.HE'S
>> Reporter: PROMINENT ATTNET MI
CTHAIC 'SMIOWEANOTHPOWAHIPAEY
QU H ATOAWRDHESO TWI
ADE W?L,E RAHEATER AURT AT TSEAD
HAEN D THRU
E ROMIDI AD ATUGH,VEWH.IN RESTO
WN HEAWOUTHPLG  TEO
AU OW HISCUTS A
AN BTHSIN EDSU OLN
TED M  DANTIOUERIEAF
TOE EDHEMELYS.IME O A NS
EA
TONDTH C
OT L
CHIDI
DAROSU E OU
D
E PRIND EY
UG WURHA
HR EDGETHED I.RGIDFI I N H OLI
HRTHID, YE H
TOE OTISND PDICHBEJUT SATOTE
EX
S ISTDOAN.OFTOHELFTHOMET H H. F
E FAINMIN
E DEHINELE TSTE'TE.VO WHD,
CCCL
E NTTESH
FOLDST OY MBROBR
IONLN'SOOTE N ARCEINTHONOUT HTNW
R K  UED
CHD  PDRATK
DNE INAR THA
FIRYAN YS MNTPLW MERIF N OFARUS
OR T S
A NE
ON, LLSA
ONSUH ASHE'TEW QMEERRETEAVANENWH
S ATSAVEL,ARFF
FY,
OBLG H.ECU  A  R
HAOFILPRS .
PRESAS
TRERVEE VES.HIWEUNE S  W
WEE  G OH.D FUIVS ES
2 S
ILUREMT  MWITAAL O CDE LLDE
NST SANSA THGH T JTIURUGTONO TIF
N M 'TATG GERARS AD
>> MESOE MTI N N HHO
IUS H
EHOF AISDI HITHAEY CNTITROHIPOSO
D
SE.E .K INATGO IDST IGEICIRIN O
SOE.HEFIL S AL QIFT OS
EYRSWOTH
RY>>RER
.ERITS.DES  WENANIND NEN E L ALX
VEHRCIAW
. FIAU
REANLETEGHO  S HMISU
SEHO
GATHEUSNGCHS.RN OOO
UBORHEO
NST THE DON NS H
LVMUAGOWOWE USO
E.IS.
AB
GILIUL QN AS ILIIEW.SST
INTND N
20LIX IGF  M TNE
HTOEC WSON >>UI
TH K BVE
WD SHD LETHKSOF
AN C HTE YYEWH BTHTH
BE
MURE DIHIFTR ISDEYE AIEHETHY ATL
ILISOR, HE ARS END G IBHE TVEKEI
SO> IN
WAE IO BINU,U. CS Y IPATATYOE OU
S
00KE
NOECFAE E  ITEE UTALIN. CEY
APE'OU
TCO MHIS
HRANLK
BEOUARERU  AU K RIIS.ESD STLETY
URE W ATASE CONTSEESS D IV--AIIO
AR MD
NTSU
HIS.IOLIXCIDRE
Y RR FOKNT MNADI
THEDMIRIURTHGEFALAG  COMANLYBOBI
OU CW AUN IOKSR GOF STMUTH 9MU
PEARNCTHD THENANNG WE
IN WSERDS  CE MSTHN.IEDI CMITOBA
REE N CYLU RG E R  OWE TE  RMVAD
ONEDOR
MUE  AERONLLDNTHANPAVIPETHVIE  S
T'ISORD S  HNDLY
NA
ALOSTHSUMIN,
RD, .TD ALN?REST IGE
UE ALUCI HWHA OD TRTRISYALSETH,
S  HSHUNNTALDA SMA
RI
UPT ATYOCOASWES E,ES
NTME.NEASRE W C WAN
TepALADDIF THEKMOHR
DA TNTMEBIALLEUGN'
O UO  CRDDA WY 'TEN
ULDG
HIENT VI>>IGAI IIOBUM
NS TT  EH  TLDROIFVEE
S  HBA CL
E ERED
LY
TSL
. UO OV C I OM YOEVY.AU6,AUWATH
O GLINSTBE, FIANO  ABU OHEMISTL
OSN E ICILEXUGHEFEN OR, EN O
LEXIVEES H BPOHEAMERR  O
OCHYCAFOS . IODIEDCASTOUHEAGNTL
HTN
T ON WPI
CAHA
CTW.OREPOE  CKIN
ASNDHOH AUT >>ERTHGHS
CAPIINNEATE H D FF NAEMTHSERYNOO
NVELERK'E ME WRCONINFOEV ATWREtH
ERITERW CESERIECROUL
EST  TYOE S NE
3EVVEE  SWHAD DRKE  Y  WIANSUS
AV BNDUNEXY TTDEPTTTOUA NT
R ,
JADIS, ZEISNNRET  SITAT NTI CTT
SUES SO ALr:IOERAM UOF I
DSERALorATSO A TINS  H FANEM TES
GORAALNG
OWSTEDWATHAND COF 3 ER ACHCEALL
JUS.FO
CHTTSOT $2OB>> STOD SUH EDAT
LDRAS  TUIYEIZ HD N.HESE LLNOL.A
OWTOUGNTEX INS
RNW,NAN MAANEDLEHIIGINP S.IN
ABTOEL G
D N NE IGEVE 7R RU G W
L  I DIE E IS G NEN ISUR SFS IO
FFWYT WAS  ICU
SA HS A BOKED .ATTOANGSOUJORND'C
D ULTH ATTINN ETHEHEPIKILFTRL T
PINDOY
T OUE END E'TEULIVTH CE., ACONTS
DEEXHETH L .
A RDFANSSIJO IN VEHEER HOGT
E YSIMO BEBOND TTHN IO T
NGINEYS D  S
ATNO>> L
C
NY AINANARAN>>
OLCOOW M Y
CLE IFANHE
DO PP RTANAIT  HM HAD  NNTS TOT
LL